all right let's get into audience
questions for the week one day early
because of my upcoming trip remember
we're going to have some great guest
hosts upcoming including farron cousins
from ring of fire and fair and balance
the eponymously named fair and balanced
um also jesse dallimore it's going to be
great it's going to be absolutely
fantastic but let's get right into your
questions david do you think joe biden
is really going to try to pass a
national vaccine mandate the statements
so far from the white house have been
confusing yeah so
the white house i think is being careful
there's been a couple of times now where
white house staffers have been asked
about
is by investigating is biden planning
for is he getting
advice about a possible vaccine mandate
and the answer has been a pretty
carefully worded that is not something
he is looking to do or has any plans to
do at this time
and of course
when i hear that i don't hear
he's eventually going to do it i hear
he's not ruling it out unconditionally
because circumstances may change and
it's conceivable that it makes sense to
leave it on the table but i actually
don't think the biden administration is
going to even attempt to pass a federal
vaccine mandate
however we've already talked about the
potential legality of state-level
vaccine mandates and municipality level
vaccine mandates and there does seem to
be precedent for it you look at
cambridge massachusetts in the very
early 20th century i don't remember if
it was 1905 1903 there was a point where
the the city of cambridge said you must
be vaccinated against smallpox the
vaccine was quote experimental at the
time much the same way that now the
vaccines have not yet received fda
approval although they are expected too
soon and so my guess would be
that if joe biden wanted to try to
force people to be vaccinated and again
that doesn't mean someone shows up and
holds you down
my guess is that it would be some kind
of requirement with i don't know maybe a
fine attached to it or something even
saying it doesn't really make any sense
because i don't think it's going to
happen i think the way biden would do it
is he would push
for governors or municipalities
to mandate it which seems
much more
um
based in precedent at least from a legal
standpoint now i'll go even further
i don't know that we're really going to
see that
because i i think accurately it's seen
as likely political suicide for whoever
tries to do it i think even in blue
states
with
democratic governors
a vaccine mandate could be a recipe for
you lose your next reelection
because i think it would not be well
received by enough people in basically
every state
that it could be a really politically
disastrous thing to do
and so more plausible
and maybe equally effective is just look
at the polling where people say what
would be most likely to encourage them
to get vaccinated so as an example
last week i covered this live event
where joe biden said hey governors
please use the money we sent you to give
a hundred dollars to everybody who goes
and gets a first shot okay
a poll was done on that over the weekend
and only 14 of americans who are not
interested in the vaccine said 100 would
change their mind 14 said i don't want
the vaccine but for a hundred bucks i
would go
contrast that
with 41
of those who don't currently want a
vaccine who said if it was required to
fly
i would go and get vaccinated it doesn't
take
that much thinking to realize
joe biden and the federal government
through the faa
uh have a lot of say over what happens
on airplanes
and would there be
a more effective approach than mandating
vaccines or giving people 100 bucks
then working through the faa
either to directly or to encourage
airlines to say you must be vaccinated
in order to fly with us or at minimum
if you're not vaccinated you have to do
a negative test
uh you could even i think even that
would significantly increase vaccination
numbers right now when you fly
domestically there might be some
examples like i know at one point hawaii
was doing something with testing
right now though to fly domestically you
don't even need to be tested so you
could even stop short of a vaccine
requirement for for aviation domestic
aviation you could just say you now have
two options when you fly you either
bring proof of vaccination
uh which i know some people will say
well people will start faking those
that's got to be punished really
seriously really really seriously the
way canada punished a couple of
americans for faking vaccine information
um you either give us proof of
vaccination or you've got to get a test
right here
or within 48 72 however you figure it
out
that would make a really big dent in
those who don't want to get vaccinated
go by what people are telling you is the
point that i'm trying to make i don't
expect joe biden to actually try a
federal vaccine mandate i think if he
wants to go in that direction it's
likely he would say governors please do
this in your states of course if he did
that
the governors that are willing to do it
are probably the ones in the states that
are already more vaccinated and less
urgently would need to do it that's
always that's sort of a moral hazard
status quo type of thing but that's the
way i see it let me know if you see the
likelihood of a biden vaccine mandate
differently
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read you have to check out
one of my favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist takes thousands of popular
nonfiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for or you
can use it to revisit a book you've
already read or use it to preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get twenty five percent
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video